GRIFF: WELL, IT’S OFFICIAL THE
G.O.P. CONVENTION IS HEADING TO
THE SUNSHINE STATE THIS SUMMER.
THE RNC UNANIMOUSLY DECIDING TO
SCALE DOWN CONVENTION PLANS IN
CHARLOTTE, NORTH CAROLINA AND
HOST A CELEBRATORY ASPECT IN
JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA INCLUDING
THE PRESIDENT’S ACCEPTANCE
SPEECH.
HERE WITH WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
HIS GREAT CITY JACKSONVILLE
MAYOR GOOD MORNING.
MR. MAYOR.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GRIFF: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF BEING
CHOSEN AS THE PLACE WHERE THIS
WILL HAPPEN?
>> WELL, WE ARE GRATEFUL IT’S
GOING TO BE HERE.
WE WERE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE THE
ABILITY TO PUT TOGETHER AND PUT
ON AN EVENT IN A SAFE,
RESPONSIBLE WAY AS WE EMERGE
FROM COVID-19.
WE WERE RESPONSIBLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
WE CAME OUT OF IT WITH -- WE
FLATTENED THE CURVE PRETTY
QUICKLY OVERTIME.
OUR HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE LOW.
WE DEMONSTRATED A MONTH AGO THAT
WE CAN PUT ON EVENTS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO OPERATE OUT
OF FEAR.
WE ARE GOING TO OPERATE OUT OF
DATA SCIENCE AND GET PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY.
THAT’S WHAT THIS CONVENTION IS.
GRIFF: I HAVE TO ASK YOU, MAYOR,
YOU ARE SEEING A RISE, A SPIKE
IN CASES IN FLORIDA.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION
PARTICULARLY SHOULD THIS
CONTINUE TO BE THE CASE?
>> WELL, WE ARE TESTING.
WE HAVE GOT A NUMBER OF TESTING
SIGHTS UP.
SITES UP.
ON THE FRONT END WHEN THE
PANDEMIC ADDED WE WILL ADD.
WHEN ALL THIS STARTED ALL THE
EXPERTS GO FLATTEN THE CURVE,
PROTECT THE HOSPITAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS.
WITHOUT A VACCINE THE VIRUS IS
WITH US.
WE HAVE DONE THAT IN
JACKSONVILLE.
WE HAVE DONE THAT IN FLORIDA.
OUR HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE LOW.
WE WATCHED THAT DAILY.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO LEARN TO
LIVE WITH THIS VIRUS IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY.
TAKE CARE OF THOSE THAT ARE MOST
LIKELY TO GET IT AND END UP WITH
SYMPTOMS IN THE HOSPITAL.
BUT WE HAVE GOT TO GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK.
WE HAVE WITHIN DOING THAT NOW
FOR WEEKS.
WORKING WITH OUR GOVERNOR.
AND WE’RE GOING TO PUT ON A BIG
EVENT AND HAVE A MAJOR ECONOMIC
IMPACT FOR OUR BUSINESSES.
GRIFF: MR. MAYOR, I DON’T WANT
TO PUT YOU ON THE SPOT.
I HAVE A VERY INTERESTING
QUESTION HAVING COVERED A LOT OF
CONVENTIONS.
THIS ONE WILL BE LIKE ANY OTHER.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE SEEING PEOPLE
WITH MASKS, WEARING MASKS?
>> WELL, LOOK, THIS IS 8 TO 10
WEEKS OUT.
SO WHATEVER THE PROTOCOLS ARE
THEN, WE WILL HAVE THEM IN PLACE
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE SAFE.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE TEMPERATURE
CHECKS.
BUT, GO BACK JUST A MONTH AND A
HALF, TWO MONTHS AGO.
THERE WERE EXPERTS SAYING THERE
WOULD BE NO SPORTS THIS SUMMER
OR THE FALL.
THERE WERE EXPERTS SAYING THEME
PARKS WOULDN’T BE REOPENED.
THAT STUFF IS HAPPENING NOW.
SO, IF OUR TRENSDZ CONTINUE, WE
ARE -- WE HAVE BEEN HEADED THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AS WE REPHASE
OUR REOPENINGS.
WE EXPECT TO HAVE A FULL ARENA
AND CELEBRATE THE RENOMINATION
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
GRIFF: YOU SAY A LOT IS
HAPPENING.
LISTEN, YOU HAVE THE G.O.P.
CONVENTION AND I EVEN SAW
CAPTAIN SANDY FROM BELOW DECK,
106-YEAR-OLD FIREHOUSE BUILDING
IS JACKSONVILLE THE PLACE TO BE
IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW?
>> IT IS THE PLACE TO BE.
YES, I MET WITH HER YESTERDAY.
WE HAVE MAJOR ECONOMIC BOOM
DEVELOPMENT HAPPENING THAT
STARTED BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
AND PEOPLE ARE READY TO GET
MOVING.
SHE BOUGHT AN OLD FIREHOUSE.
SHE IS GOING TO DO COOL STUFF
THERE, INCLUDING A RESTAURANT.
ALSO SHE HAS A GREAT IDEA.
THE WAY THAT OUR RIVER SETS, THE
DEPTH OF IT, WE ARE ONE OF THE
FEW CITIES WHERE YOU CAN BRING A
SUPER YACHT IN AND ACTUALLY GET
IT OUT OF THE WATER IF YOU NEED
TO FOR PURPOSES.
WE’RE ON THE MOVE.
COME TO EXPWRAXZVILLE.
GRIFF: ALL RIGHT.